COUNTRY.
I'M SORRY YOU AND YOUR YOUNG
FRIENDS HAVE GONE THROUGH
THIS.
>> THANK YOU.
>> Jason: NRA IMMEDIATELY
FILED SUIT TODAY TO BLOCK A
NEW GUN CONTROL LAW SIGNED
BY GOVERNOR SCOTT.
>> AFTER REVIEWING THE
ENTIRE BILL I HAD TO ASK
MYSELF, WOULD THIS BIG BILL
MAKE A HUGE INVESTMENT AND
DRAMATICALLY IMPROVE SCHOOL
SAFETY IN HOPES OF NEVER
SEEING ANOTHER TRAGEDY LIKE
THIS AGAIN?
WILL THIS BILL PROVIDE MORE
FUNDING TO TREAT THE
MENTALLY ILL?
WILL THIS BILL GIVE FAR MORE
TOOLS TO KEEP GUNS AWAY FROM
PEOPLE WHO SHOULD NOT HAVE
THEM?
THE ANSWER TO ALL THREE IS
YES.
>> Jason: NOT EVERYONE
THINKS THE ANSWER IS YES.
JOINING ME FROM ORLANDO IS
REPUBLICAN CONGRESSMAN RON
DESANTIS.
RON AND I SERVED IN THE
UNITED STATES CONGRESS
TOGETHER.
WE WERE ON THE SAME
OVERSIGHT COMMITTEE AS WELL
AS THE JUDICIARY COMMITTEE.
HE IS ALSO NOW RUNNING FOR
THE GOVERNOR OF FLORIDA.
CONGRESSMAN DESANTIS, THANKS
SO MUCH FOR JOINING US.
>> HEY, JASON, GOOD TO SEE
YOU.
>> Jason: THE GOVERNOR
SIGNED A BILL.
WOULD YOU, IF YOU WERE
ELECTED GOVERNOR, WOULD YOU
HAVE SIGNED THAT BILL?
>> I THINK I WOULD HAVE
APPROACHED IT A LITTLE BIT
DIFFERENT.
I THINK CERTAINLY THE SCHOOL
SECURITY I THINK IS LONG
OVERDUE.
THE MONEY FOR MENTAL HEALTH
AND BEING ABLE TO IDENTIFY
THESE INDIVIDUALS WHO ARE
DANGEROUS SO THAT THEY ARE
NOT ABLE TO POSSESS WEAPONS.
I THINK ALL OF THOSE ARE
GOOD.
I THINK WHEN YOU START
GETTING INTO SOME OF THE
BLANKET RESTRICTIONS ON
PEOPLE'S SECOND AMENDMENT
RIGHTS, I THINK THAT IS
CONSTITUTIONALLY VULNERABLE.
I THINK THOSE LAWSUITS ARE
PROBABLY GOING TO SUCCEED.
I MEAN, THINK ABOUT IT.
HAVE YOU ENUMERATED RIGHT IN
THE BILL OF RIGHTS.
THERE IS REALLY NO PRECEDENT
TO JUST DO A BLANKET BAN ON
CERTAIN ADULTS.
I MEAN, WE WOULDN'T SAY THAT
IF YOU ARE 18 TO 20 YOU
DON'T HAVE A FOURTH EASEMENT
RIGHT AND POLICE COULD
SEARCH YOUR HOUSE WITHOUT A
WARRANT.
WE WOULDN'T SAY THAT THEY
COULD SEIZE YOUR PROPERTY
WITHOUT JUST IF THE FIFTH
AMENDMENT DOESN'T APPLY.
I THINK THAT'S PROBLEMATIC.
I DON'T THINK THAT PROVISION
WILL ACTUALLY PREVENT ANY
GUN CRIMES.
HERE'S THE THING AND YOU
KNOW MORE THAN ANYBODY IN
DEALING ON THE OVERSIGHT.
WE WORKED TOGETHER FOR
YEARS, THIS BETWEEN THE
LOCALS AND BROWARD CUT, AND
BETWEEN THE FEDERAL WITH THE
FBI WAS THE MOST
CATASTROPHIC FAILURE OF
GOVERNMENT THAT I HAVE
WITNESSED SINCE I HAVE BEEN
IN THE CONGRESS OR WHEN I
SERVED IN THE MILITARY.
YOU GUYS MENTIONED THE
DIFFERENT WARNINGS THAT WERE
GIVEN ON THE SCENE.
OBVIOUSLY THEY WENT TO THE
GUY'S HOUSE 3 TIMES.
THEY HAD AMPLE OPPORTUNITY
TO ARREST HIM.
THEY DIDN'T DO IT.
WE THEN GOT A BRIEFING THIS
WEEK IN WASHINGTON FROM THE
FBI.
NOT ONLY DID THEY GET A
GREAT TIP IN JANUARY.
NOT ONLY DID THEY GET A TIP
THE PREVIOUS YEAR 2017 IN
MISSISSIPPI.
THE CALLER IN 2018 WHO TOOK
IT FBI ACTUALLY CONNECTED
THE TWO TO THE MISSISSIPPI
ONE.
SO THEY KNEW THIS GUY WAS
DANGEROUS.
AND THEY MADE THE DECISION
NOT EVEN TO ALERT THE LOCAL
AUTHORITIES.
AND SO, WE CAN ARGUE ABOUT
DIFFERENT LAWS.
THE FACT IS THE LAWS THAT
WERE ON THE BOOKS WERE
SUFFICIENT TO PREVENT THIS
HAD GOVERNMENT DONE ITS JOB.
>> Jason: NOW, ONE OF THE
PROVISIONS IN THERE IS TO,
IN FLORIDA, AND IT'S
AVAILABLE IN OTHER STATES,
FOR INSTANCE, IN UTAH.
THERE ARE TEACHERS AND
SCHOOL OFFICIALS WHO CAN
CARRY WEAPONS.
ARE YOU IN FAVOR OF THAT?
DO YOU THINK THAT WOULD
HELP?
>> I WOULD NOT MANDATE ANY
TEACHERS TO CARRY OR
ADMINISTRATORS.
WHAT I WOULD DO IS SAY A
SCHOOL SHOULD NOT BE
ADVERTISED AS A GUN-FREE
ZONE.
IF YOU HAVE MAYBE IT'S ONE
OR TWO FACULTY MEMBERS WHO
HAVE A LICENSE, HAVE A
CONCEAL CARRY PERMIT.
I DON'T THINK THEY SHOULD BE
PREDICTED FROM USING THAT
BRINGING THE FIREARM IN A
CONCEALED WAY ON CAMPUS.
THE REASON IS EVEN IF NO ONE
DECIDES TO DO IT, JUST THE
FACT THAT IT MIGHT BE THERE,
I THINK THAT GIVES POTENTIAL
SHOOTER PAUSE AND IF YOU ARE
BEEFING UP THE OUTSIDE
SECURITY AND YOU ARE
HARDENING THE SCHOOLS.
THEN GUESS WHAT IN THE
SCHOOLS ARE NO LONGER SUCH
AN INVITING TARGET.
I MEAN, WE HAVE KIND OF LET
THESE THINGS BE SITTING
DUCKS AND THERE IS SICKNESS
IN SOCIETY WITH SOME OF
THESE REALLY DEMENTED
INDIVIDUALS THAT ARE
ATTRACTED TO THAT.
I THINK JUST SAYING THAT A
CONCEAL CARRY PERMIT HOLDER
CAN GO TO CAMPUS AND TEACH
AND INSTRUCT WITH THAT I
THINK THAT WOULD SERVE AS
DETERRENT TO PEOPLE TO TREAT